it seems like when you're doing a
creature or uh you know some
you know character in a movie and you
have prosthetics on you have all these
things on it feels like especially if
you don't speak a lot it you have to
[Music]
it's your body that expresses all these
things your your emotions and things and
things have to come out and it just
seems like that's harder you know if you
have lines you could say some lines and
people go oh that's sad that his brother
died
but when you have to mode all this [ __ ]
right i mean doesn't that don't you have
to work harder you think
yeah sure
well
you have to work different maybe not
harder um
i believe that dialogue comes in uh
visuals and verbal right right and we
all we all speak it every day but we're
just not as we're not so aware of the
visuals uh that we're giving so when you
are playing a creature that that has no
written verbal dialogue lines
uh you have tons of dialogue that is
visual to get a point across to get an
emotional crops to get a relationship
across uh the shape of water is probably
the most
the most near and dear to me as far as
the non-verbal characters that i've
played right the amphibian man in that
didn't speak a word he was an animal
from the wild and he's falling in love
with a mute woman so she didn't speak
either so the two of us had to find good
lords and completely on-screen language
with each other that the audience would
buy right yeah so so i i've had tons of
dialogue over the years whether it's
whether it's spoken or shown right but
you know we'll get into this again shape
of water but i know that
uh the director i always messed his name
up
i've heard everything over there oh you
must what's it like working with
guillermo what's up with guermotaro
um
but he said something to you in the
shape of water before you started
filming yes i saw an interview with you
oh and he said something to you which
sounds pretty frightening but it's like
what did he say to you
you would be the romantic leading man of
this movie is that the way you're
talking about yup exactly and right and
i'm thinking like you just told me about
this being a fish person so that's gonna
be there's a tall order right you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah but but then
but the next breath i thought to myself
guillermo del toro is the one director
who can pull this off as far as like
writing it and guiding me through it and
he sure did but didn't he say something
like you're playing an animal
and uh but you have to be we have to
love you yeah yeah oh yeah i
have to
the audience has to has to buy that this
woman is falling in love with me
uh so i have to have a romance to me i
have to have a sexy look the look of the
amphibian man went through a year of
tweaks and changes and color changes and
shape changes the ass and the lips were
the two areas on the fish man that were
the most retooled over the over really
they wanted you to have a nice ass oh
gosh yeah and i'll tell you what uh i
knew that they pulled that off uh it was
glued onto me by the way it wasn't my
ass i had to give it back every day but
but
but i knew i knew the ass was working
when we're all sitting on our set chairs
you know between shot setups and i stand
up to walk away and octavia spencer says
that's when i knew that we pulled it off
really yeah
you